how are you oh i'm so good i'm in a
dress i'm in heels
i'm straight coming from camera blocking
look at these heels
coming straight from dancing with the
stars camera blocking i'm good and
you've got the rainbow eye shadow
representing you know honestly i was
like i want to be sleek tonight but i
was like okay
i can't fully dish out on colors you
know what i mean i was like i gotta have
a little something i love it well girl
congratulations on everything you are
dancing your way into the finals
what are you going to bring to the dance
floor oh my gosh i am so excited so the
finals are tomorrow night um monday
night 8 p.m eastern voting is open at 8
pm eastern texas 2 5 2 3 10 times we
need your votes to win the mirror ball
um we i'm really pumped up we have a
fusion number which is for us it's a
tango and a cha-cha which is so fun and
then for a freestyle
i honestly want it to be a surprise what
it is because our song that we get to
dance to is probably the most meaningful
song to me
and the dance that we do is so magical
and i'm not going to spoil but the last
20 seconds
are the 20 seconds in this entire season
that i'm most grateful for
for sure okay so if that mirror ball is
yours how emotional will that moment be
for you you have been through a lot the
last few months we have we have been
through a lot i will say this no matter
what i'm going to be very emotional
tomorrow night i am going to be so sad
that it's over i was saying today i was
like oh my gosh i'm going to look like
such a sore loser because i'm going to
be sobbing but not because i didn't win
but because it's over um if i don't win
but if i do win i'm still gonna be
stopping because it's over and i'm gonna
be so happy that i'm gonna be stopping
um it's it's
been a dream come true to be on this
show and so to be in the finale already
it's just even more dream come true and
to win would just
be everything and to have this show
obviously come at a time in your
personal life experiencing a breakup how
much has that dance floor helped you
through you know i i hope jenna doesn't
see this right now because this is
something that i wrote in her card that
i'm giving to her tomorrow so if you're
watching this
new video
i said that there was days where the
only thing that i wanted to do was go to
rehearsals go dance with jen just go
take my mind off of everything and go
dance and that is something that going
through a breakup and going through a
heartbreak i was so grateful that i had
it was denser than stars was my little
like happiness outlet for for the last
10 weeks so i'm really thankful for that
are you doing good now heart's doing
good heart's doing good heart is heart
has her moments
she likes to have her fun but she's good
and that's all that matters in the
meantime you're wearing dancing with the
stars near your heart
always i got my dancing stars and my j
nation i love it congratulations on
everything so good to see you